yeah welcome to this video playing Alexa
ah Alexa arm from the US let's see
kingsland yin yeah let's play the h3
line and get it to benoni yeah check he
takes d5 this is quite a good line at
turn give some now he's playing all this
very quickly when did sir it's simply a
bad line for blacking pretty pretty
surprising that he is playing the Sun
instantly all of that it's a it's a
problem because when the dark squares
are seriously weakened on blacks King
side and I'll get lots of pressure on
the F file rook f2f1 commune age 6 this
kind of ideas so it's known for quite
some time that this Bishop h6 isn't a
good line let's see how is trying to
defend a problem is also that his pieces
are simply stepping on each other's toes
it's very difficult to to to get some
meaningful coordination going if you
place night h5 intending large III on
rogue everyone I can even play G form
yeah and here can I can just take I
think I should I play look everyone know
any place night this happen I shouldn't
do that so just pile up on f6 yeah now
is already almost forced to give up give
up material
now okay King to h1 maybe 9 h 5 but I
can play an IT to first and then take
and then take on sm so not a problem
first like a burn g3 and then I can take
us soon there's also G form which is
probably simply good let's see where
he's going if he goes to g7 left Queen
g4 even Winston at night and here ok on
g4 he can give this check so I probably
should not do that let's just grab f7 no
it's also a bit difficult to get pieces
developed bishop on b7 cannot move
another idea of course is Queen h6 he
has 97 now to defend against that for
the moment yes but this route takes a
five at least rook takes at five um is
there something better even yeah okay
come on it's 11 winning line is enough
I'll just take the night next move if I
give the check I take Queen takes and
Ruby five wins the Queen it's simply yes
no square to protect the night and then
I'm material up and still have this
attack against the king
mmm come on don't don't don't let the
clock run down this is really not
necessary right yeah I guess it's simply
not responding
yeah not much to say maybe I can quickly
recap the game oh no is no is giving me
this the Queen this way check black
resigned okay so um let's recap the
problem really is a special page six
more check looks very normal but the
problem is it takes so much time and
black cannot really take the pawn him I
mean this is giving up too much time
there's all kinds of direct the text
coming and piling up here it's I've got
everything developed while black still
has pieces in the corner so he cannot
take so 9070 form and he does not get
his knights coordinated if for instance
i had the porn on edge to it he would be
able to play 9485 this is a different
story but you don't they don't manage
that simply and they would a six covers
d6 but against that be five to six I
mean and he it's already super difficult
to play 95 we saw what happened but it's
it's very hard to even roughly keep the
game going Brooke f1 it's so much coming
how to hard to repair this this kind of
opening it's got an awful score for
black only recently I saw some
relatively good players stumbling to
that I forgot about it who it was but
pretty it was pretty surprised yeah it's
simply not playable this line I mean in
blitz chess lots of things can be can be
done and you're not punished all the
time but this is a line that you really
should avoid in long term and long term
play in short also but I
why just got some time in the probably
punish it every time this is kind of
inaccurate setup alright thanks for
watching